Before we set this video. I just want to mention that only 16% of you are subscribed
So if you enjoy the content, please hit the subscribe button. Hey, everyone
Welcome to another installment of Harry Potter theory in this video
We're going to be discussing the five most powerful witches wizards that came from Gryffindor House at Hogwarts in the last video we discussed
Slytherin and you guys seem to enjoy it
So I'm going to be making one of these videos for each of the four houses
Now of the four houses with those who are destined to be sovereigns aside
Gryffindor is seemingly the house that many people want to be in sure
It's not for everyone but in a weird way
It's sort of the popular house that gets all of the glory in McGonigle's own words, though
She might be biased having been christened or herself
The house of God Rick Griffin doll has commanded the respect of the Wizarding World for nearly 10 centuries
Many of the other houses over the years speculated that Gryffindor has received favoritism from the Hogwarts staff
however
Despite their differences with Gryffindor Hufflepuff and ravenclaw have also always been on the side of Gryffindor in the ongoing rivalry
Between Slytherin and Gryffindor the sorting hat describes the criteria for Gryffindor as follows
You might belong in Gryffindor where dwelled the brave at heart
Their daring nerve and chivalry set Gryffindor's apart in short what this basically means is a defining
Characteristic of a Gryffindor is courage or bravery
Hogwarts had four founders Rowena Ravenclaw South's a Slytherin Elgar Hufflepuff and Godric Gryffindor
Each of the four founders formed their very own house at the school and Gryffindor House
Which of course found it by Godric?
After founding the school the four founders encountered a bit of a dilemma
When it occurred to them that it would have to figure out a way to sort students by house when they were no longer alive
However, this dilemma was short-lived as Godric Gryffindor quickly provided a solution to their problem
Godric pulled his completely normal hat off of his head and made the suggestion to the other founders that using their collective magic
They enchant the Hat and turn it into a sentient being
the four founders of Hogwarts recognized that they valued very different virtues
Virtues which ended up leading to the defining attributes of each house
It was important to them that the houses they founded would continue to follow by the beliefs from which they were based
These virtues or inherent characteristics can be summed up in the sorting hats own words by Gryffindor
The bravest were prized far beyond the rest for ravenclaw
the cleverest would always be the best for Hufflepuff hard workers were must worthy of admission and
Power-hungry sovereign loved those of great ambition
There it is again prized far beyond the rest boy
after the students placed the hat on their head it begins to analyze their mind and
places them in a house based on how closely they resemble one of the four founders in the same way that becoming evil is not
A defining characteristic of cedron being arrogant is not a defining
Characteristic of a Gryffindor and this is the reputation that they seem to get
Like so they're in Gryffindor houses produced some of the greatest and most powerful wizards
The world has ever seen one of the reasons that Gryffindor students and southern students have such a seemingly embedded
Rivalry is because Hogwarts founders Godric Gryffindor and Salazar Slytherin had a falling out of a sovereign's emphasis on blood purity
despite their courageous reputation some feel that their courage is mainly exercised by engaging in pointless heroics and
Severus Snape always found Gryffindor's to be self-righteous and arrogant though
He could just be saying this because he disliked the Marauders
The top 5 list for Gryffindor was actually much harder to produce than a list for Sutherland as I feel that there are many witches
And wizards from Gryffindor House. Is it quite comparable in terms of power?
There are also some characters that I feel like should be in Gryffindor
But we just don't have any proof to support it ie Rufus Scrimgeour
He was such a powerful wizard and if he was a Gryffindor
Which he might have been he definitely would have made this list though
I know that some feel he was more of a southern maybe there's a topic for another video
So without further ado, let's take a look the five
most powerful Gryffindor's to have ever lived at least the ones that we know about number 5 Sirius Black
first of all
Let me start off by saying that it was really hard for me to decide between Remus and Sirius this position on the list
They grew up together in the booth particularly powerful wizards in their own, right?
Remus has the added threat of being able to transform into a werewolf
But I think that serious and this is just my opinion is a slightly more powerful one out of the pair
We know Sirius Black as The Godfather of Harry Potter and one of the Marauders series started at Hogwarts in the year
1971 the same year that Peter Pettigrew
Remus Lupin and James Potter began attending the school the quartet of boys would eventually form a group called Marauders and
one thing that they all had in common was they were all
Gryffindor's the Marauders were hell-bent on breaking the rules at the school and were notorious for their rule breaking and mischief making
Though they were mischief makers
they were all very magically talented and serious ended up becoming an animagus the ripe age of 15 an
Extremely impressive feat his animagus form is a black dog, and it was by transforming into his animagus form
Then he was able to escape through the bars at Azkaban
Sirius hailed from the powerful visiting family the blacks and while many of his family members placed an unreasonable amount of value on blood purity
Series did not share this same belief many of the members of the black family went down a very dark path serious
Cousin Bellatrix Lestrange is a great example of this
Serious didn't want his lineage to determine the man that he would become and once wisely said we've all got both light and dark
Inside us. What matters is the part we choose to act on that's who we really are
While his magical development was somewhat stunted by the extensive amount of time that he spent in Azkaban
he still ended up being a supremely powerful wizard in addition to becoming an animagus Sirius was skilled at
Transfiguration in general not only that, but he was also skilled at brewing potions
Producing charms producing nonverbal magic and Aquaman see Sirius met his demise at the hands of his cousin Bellatrix
But she's one of the most powerful witches to have ever lived. So it's not like he went down easy number four Peter Pettigrew
I know what you're thinking Peter Pettigrew. How is he on this list?
Just hear me out Peter Pettigrew also known as Wormtail was a British pure but wizard born in 1959
He had pale skin unhealthy hair and blue eyes too most he was considered to be a sniveling excuse for a man
Whose loyalties only lay where there was power
but in his younger years
He did sort of have friends and was one of the members of the Marauders along with Sirius Remus and James
Pettigrew like Sirius successfully became an animagus at a very young age and although it took Pettigrew longer than Sirius
It doesn't automatically mean that Sirius was a more gifted wizard many witches and wizards as well as fans of the series
Automatically right off Pettigrew's magical capabilities due to his appearance and meek demeanor
However, the truth is that Pettigrew was a talented wizard. He was also just equally mentally weak and quite impressionable
Pettigrew didn't perform well at school, but it seemed like during his time at school
He was more focused on just causing trouble with his friends
Additionally some people just struggle in their younger years and go on to accomplish greater and more impressive things once they've gotten a little bit
older
I think that Pettigrew fits this category perfectly in addition to becoming an animagus which is an advanced form of Transfiguration
Pettigrew was also first in conjuration. Another extremely advanced branch of Transfiguration
Conjuration which allows individuals to transfigure an object out of thin air was only taught to talented students at the newt level
He could also brew highly advanced potions under the instruction of Lord Voldemort
he successfully helped to produce both the rudimentary body potion and
Regeneration potion. He also along with Barty Crouch jr
Produced a Polyjuice potion, which is very involved though
I don't necessarily believe that Pettigrew is much more powerful than Sirius or Remus with regards to
conventional forms of magic
I do think that he is much more versed in the dark arts as neither Sirius nor Remus had much experience with the dark arts
Pettigrew could easily and successfully cast Avada Kedavra which requires extreme concentration
Additionally in 1981 the same year the Pettigrew frame Sirius for the death of 12 muggles
He utilized the dark advanced and powerful blasting curse. The curse was strong enough to murder
Twelve people destroy hundreds of feet of sewer system and leave a 40-foot crater in the ground
Because he had such a broad Wizarding Arsenal. I think that he is deserving of the number-4 spot on this list number three, Minerva McGonagall
Minerva McGonagall is a Scottish half fat witch that attended the Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and Wizardry and later worked there
while she attended the school
She was the most talented student of her entire year and she achieved top grades in her newts and owls
She exhibited extreme magical prowess from a very young age and later became one of Hogwarts best professors
McGonigle's most notable skill is perhaps related to her knowledge and talent in
Transfiguration she is known for her effortless ability to transform her physical form at will
McGonigle was extremely proficient at transfiguration
Very early on and she became an animagus at a very young age
She later became a head of transfiguration at Hogwarts a position that she took very seriously as she believed
Transfiguration be one of the most complex and dangerous forms of magic taught at the school
she was also highly proficient at casting a wide variety of charms and
Mastered the Patronus charm in both corporeal and incorporeal forms when she was still very young
she was also a skilled potion maker able to successfully brew an animagus potion and
dualist notably Zhu Ling Lord, Voldemort to a standstill alongside Slughorn and Kingsley
But what makes McGonagall particularly powerful is her paired knowledge of the dark arts. Not only did she master charms
Transfiguration dueling and potion making she also had a vast knowledge of the dark arts though. She didn't use dark spells frequently
She could use them when necessary and notably used the Imperius curse on amicus Cara number two Godric Gryffindor
We don't actually have a lot of information on Godric Gryffindor
But we know that the founders of Hogwarts all four of them were immensely powerful
The Hogwarts founders are widely thought to have possessed power that was entirely and comparable to most modern-day witches and wizards
Godric was a tall muscular man was a lion like mane of hair. This is representative of the Gryffindor crest which contains a lion
Gryffindor was unusual as a wizard and that he would often duel with the sword rather fertile wand
This was to give people a fighting chance
He was also an extremely impressive swordsman and his sword
The Sword of Gryffindor is massively important in the series
Godric was also a charms master and along with the other three founders helped him chant the sorting hat
Effectively turning it into a sentient being funnily enough who was actually his hat to begin with
Like I said before we just don't have a lot of information on the man
But I still think that I can confidently place him this high up in the list
Because time and time again the founders have been referenced as exceedingly powerful
Rowling herself said that Gryffindor was the most accomplished jeweler of his time
number one
Dumbledore now, I'm sure you saw this coming
D'Amato is undoubtedly the most powerful wizard to have ever lived
Comparable only to maybe Voldemort or possibly Grindle wat while at school Dumbledore's magical abilities consistently turn heads
Particularly his skills surrounding charms and Transfiguration
He also did exceptionally well on his newts and Griselda Marchbanks a professor working for the Wizarding examinations authority
Remark that Albus was able to do things with the wand that she had never seen before in
Addition to being a charms and Transfiguration master gum model was also an expert
practitioner of elemental magic over the course of the books and films
He's really shown us what he's capable of and in his jewel against Voldemort in the ministry atrium
We see his elemental expertise shine through and he creates some sort of complicated
Hydrokinetic spell I think that his most impressive display of magic period was when he produced firestorm to ward off the in faerie
firestorm produces a large ring of fire from the caster's wand and
From this ring the caster is able to shoot Jets or balls of fire at opponents
There truly isn't a subject or area of magic where Dumbledore is lacking and he's truly a master in Transfiguration charms potions
Elemental magic, ah clemency and more. He is the exception to the phrase
jack of all trades master of none as he was truly a jack of all trades master of all and
That's it for this list honorable mentions include Harry Potter Hermione Granger Remus Lupin and James Potter
This is not to say that there aren't other powerful Gryffindor's. These are just the ones that nearly made the
What do you guys think who were your top five? Let me know down in the comment section below
until next time YER wizard ARRY